italiani sulle principali riviste cura
uno spazio blog di approfondimento
sull'affinton post Italia e in Unicef
Italia dal 2008 prima come capo ufficio
stampa e poi dal 2012 come portavoce
Nazionale siamo molto felici di
accogliere Andrea iacomini che questa
sera terrà uno speech dal titolo a loro
pensa papà buon ascolto
[Applauso]
grazie grazie Buonasera a tutti
è bello
è molto bello poter ricordare
Io in realtà se mi avessero detto Tanti
anni fa che avrei fatto il giornalista
Ok avrei fatto il portavoce di
organizzazione unitaria
addirittura delle Nazioni Unite che si
occupa di bambini non ci avrei creduto
come tutti i bambini
volevo fare il calciatore poi mi sono
accorto che chiaramente
ogni volta che giocavo mi fermavano le
gambe anche se ero bravino e ho lasciato
stare allora poi
da più grande quasi adolescente ricordo
che a un certo punto volevo fare
l'attore
Però anche fare l'attore di teatro
richiede di non essere timidi avere un
problema non avere problemi col pubblico
perlomeno non poteva essere terapeutico
Ma insomma non ho creduto neanche a
questo non l'ho fatto
mi ricordo però
che
quando ero avevo circa 15 anni nel 1989
mia madre ogni mattina
aveva questa brutta usanza particolare
diciamo Più che altro lo fanno tante
mamme la mia in particolare veniva nella
mia stanza alzava le tapparelle
si portava presso due riviste dell'epoca
mi sembra l'Espresso E Panorama tanto
per non scontentare nessuno e me le
sbatteva sul comodino e mi svegliava e
mi diceva basta Tu dormi sempre ma tu
non ti rendi conto di quello che succede
nel mondo ma tu ti stai rendendo conto
che sta crollando il muro di Berlino
ci blocchi non c'è più partito comunista
non c'è il capitalismo Ma possibile che
non riesce a interessarti di questa roba
qua non fai altro che dormire e mi
metteva Questa rivista così e mi diceva
Ma guarda che in questo momento in
Africa Guarda c'era un video a quel
tempo di Michael Jackson si chiama Man
in the Mirror dove passavano dei volti
straordinari Nelson Mandela era appena
uscito di prigione Madre Teresa di
Calcutta c'erano delle immagini
bellissime di Robert Kennedy di Tutti
questi grandi padri quelli con i quali
Poi in fondo tanti di noi sono sono
cresciuti e si modelli straordinari di
aiuto e di pace e lei mi diceva
possibile Guarda c'era un'immagine in
quel video di un bambino
rinvia fra credo Comunque ai tempi in
cui vi ricordate c'erano questa Usa for
Africa We are the world concerti
straordinari le bande tutto il mondo
guardava all'Africa questo bambino mi
ricordo in questo video di Michael
Jackson piangeva in realtà aveva le
mosche nel viso mia madre mi diceva tu
Possibile che non ti interessa niente di
tutto abbiamo visto io qua avevo 15 anni
la guardavo
e le facevo il romano Scusate
a mamma Io sono un sacco di problemi
perché a 15 anni c'hai un sacco di
problemi c'avevo una ragazza che mi
piaceva che non mi voleva avevo la
squadra per cui tifavo che perdeva
sempre sono dell'Inter naturalmente
e
ppure Non avrei mai pensato da quel
giorno che vent'anni esatti dopo
quel bambino con le moschee sul viso che
piangeva perché era malnutrito perché
non aveva nulla per il quale tutto il
mondo della musica è mia madre mi
chiedeva di intervenire mi sarebbe
venuto a chiamare a casa
e mi avrebbe detto che mi sarei dovuto
occupare di loro perché il mio lavoro
oggi è quello di Dover raccontare quello
che non vi racconta nessuno prima che
accada di Dover raccontare paesi assurdi
di cui non vivrà nessuno fino a quando
magari non vi ritrovate
un bambino che muore su un barcone
perché è scappato di casa insieme a sua
madre dove era vittima di violenza di
abuso oppure del primo paese dove sono
stato mi hanno portato per la prima
volta insieme a Leone io non sapevo
neanche dove fossi se la leonessa è in
Africa centro occidentale Sono atterrato
in questo posto dove non c'era niente
non c'era neanche la pista di
atterraggio
non c'era la luce quindi ultimo in tutte
le classifiche del mondo per povertà per
violenza per tutto Ci ha girato un film
di Caprio sui diamanti ve lo ricorderete
poi vai lì e magari Vedi queste case
dove dentro Entri e pensi con la tua
mentalità anche io che ero appena
diventato portavoce tra virgolette un
po' occidentale dove stanno i letti lo
sta televisione e invece trovi soltanto
delle Buche buche tutte buche domande
perché ci sono le buche
e in realtà in quelle buche ci dormivano
mi hanno spiegato e io non ero neanche
arrivato a collegare tutto questo e
queste campagne di vaccinazioni
straordinarie che faceva la mia
organizzazione casa per casa in mezzo a
distese intere di detriti e di rifiuti
la prima volta quel ragazzo che su quel
tavolino di casa sua si vedeva Questa
rivista sbattuta così che gli doveva
ricordare che forse forse a quel tempo
si poteva fermare un'immagine e magari
guardare a quello vi racconto un
aneddoto simpatico Io ho un figlio
adolescente adesso a 14 anni si chiama
Riccardo è un ragazzo piuttosto
particolare un po' ribelle un po' che
insomma lo era già quando era molto
piccolo
quando aveva 4/5 anni noi naturalmente
come genitori lavoriamo tutti e due
quindi andava a famoso dopo scuola
mangiava
a scuola e c'erano le insegnanti
disperate perché insomma intanto ci
chiamavano c'è Riccardo non vuole
mangiare
Riccardo non mangia Riccardo si rifiuta
di mangiare come al solito le insegnanti
mi raccontò Riccardo avevano questa
grande usanza straordinaria che tutti
voi avrete praticato avrete di cui siete
stati vittime con quella frase
incredibile lo sai Riccardo che se non
mangi ci sono miliardi di bambini nel
mondo che muoiono di fame Lo sai quanti
di voi lo sai Riccardo che ci sono dei
bambini nelle guerre del pianeta Terra
che vivono in condizioni disperate
e Riccardo Guarda l'insegnante con molta
serenità e ne dice vede maestra
Io posso anche non mangiare
perché a loro pensa papà
ora Io credo che Riccardo ci è andato
abbastanza vicino Innanzitutto è una
buona soddisfazione per un padre sapere
che tuo figlio ha quasi capito che cosa
fai Cioè sostanzialmente capito che io
mi occupo di loro Ora io non aiuto
direttamente i bambini L'altro giorno mi
ha detto quanti ne hai salvati non non
c'è una cifra ho dei colleghi
straordinari in tutte le parti del mondo
che ogni giorno stanno lì 365 giorni
l'anno a portare aiuti acqua beni di
prima necessità scuole laddove ci sono
delle emergenze non vanno a scuola
stanno lì 365 giorni io che cosa devo
fare
io che cosa faccio io sono portavoce
portavoce in francese rende un po'
strano l'idea Perché di si dice por
parole e a volte diciamo in qualche modo
si fraintende un po' non mi piace tanto
perché portarol sembra quasi che se uno
che te la racconta un po' che te la deve
imbastire un po' non mi piace in inglese
è un po' più secco quando mi dicono
Sailor Spock Pearson dell'unice Sì
allora rende meglio più secoli inglesi
in realtà
portare la parola
non vuol dire costruire dei fatti in
maniera retorica
Patetica le guerre le catastrofi
raccontarveli col peggio che ti viene in
mente vuol dire
ricordare Noi abbiamo una capacità
straordinaria
dimentichiamo benissimo Siamo i numeri
uno del delle cose dimenticate ma
abbiamo grandi difficoltà a ricordare e
il lavoro del portavoce è proprio
ricordare tutti i giorni senza sosta che
esiste un mondo di bambini e bambine
quello di cui mi occupo io che vive in
situazioni differenti e ricordare che in
questo momento mettevi parlo 6000
bambini muoiono per cause prevenibili o
curabili e per ricordarvi che oltre alla
guerra in Ucraina che ha fatto più di
mille morti e sicuramente andiamo su
cifre impressionanti quella siriana ne
ha fatte dieci volte tanto quella Yemen
ne ha fatte almeno Quante la Siria
Per non parlare del milione di bambini
malnutriti per non parlare dei 24.000
Uomini e donne e bambini che da 10 anni
muoiono in mare nel nostro mare senza
che nessuno muova una parola
è per ricordarvi ogni giorno che ci sono
paesi come l'Etiopia la Somalia dove c'è
una carestia senza precedenti lo dice
pure il papa tutti i giorni ma non
godiamo di buona stampa poi lui al Papa
Io
è per ricordare tutti i giorni
che esiste tutto questo perché lo
dimentichiamo in fretta perché quando
vediamo highlandi stesso sulla sabbia i
pantaloni blu e il maglione rosso che
potrebbe essere nostro figlio ci
ricordiamo improvvisamente che c'è un
conflitto mondiale che dura da 12 anni
ci ricordiamo improvvisamente che arriva
non milioni di siriani qui in Europa ci
domandiamo Ma come è possibile tutto
questo ma dove eravamo queste frasi di
circostanza come non succederà mai più
Vi prego se io ogni volta che lo sento
decido che mi devo dimettere quando
quando prima di un telegiornale mi danno
notizie di questo tipo la bambina giorni
fa morte morta per l'esplosione su su
una nave un altro morto risente un altro
morto non lo dobbiamo consentire più
dura da dieci anni
Guardate che
i miei datori di lavoro
sono loro
e sono esigenti Perché fare il portavoce
loro
Il portavoce dei bambini è complicato
loro non mi fanno prendere mai le ferie
loro vogliono che mi occupo h24 di
quello che fanno
loro mi chiedono continuamente di
parlare di loro
loro sostanzialmente quindi sono un capo
piuttosto risoluto
e io in questi anni con la mia
organizzazione le ho ricambiati cercando
di ridurre la mortalità infantile che
pensate notizia non lo sappiamo da
vent'anni è passato da 20 milioni ogni
anno ha 10 milioni ogni anno da 22.000
al giorno come vi dicevo all'inizio a
6000 Oggi abbiamo strappato al
matrimonio precoci centinaia di migliaia
di bambini abbiamo strappato le
motivazioni genitali da tantissime altre
Eppure ce ne sono 250 milioni ancora
Eppure di matrimoni precoci ce ne sono
ancora 700 milioni nel mondo prima dei
18 anni
cerchiamo di strappare dalla
malnutrizione ogni giorno bambini in
quasi tutto il mondo in Afghanistan
avevamo riportato 9 milioni di bambine
di bambini a scuola la metà adesso di
nuovo non ri vanno a scuola e guarda
caso sono donne che sono bambine
e guarda caso in quel paese Quando le
donne e le bambine non vanno stanno al
lavoro non vanno a scuola il paese Perde
due punti e mezzo di PIL
Ma volete sapere qual è il segreto
per parlare di loro
quello con il quale io in realtà
ottengo le promozioni ogni volta dai
miei capi che sono loro e andare a casa
loro
E quando vado a casa loro
vivo con loro
calpesto il posto dove Loro camminano
mangio con loro
ascolto quello che hanno da dirmi
vivo la loro quotidianità e li osservo E
dopo che li osservati
Io torno qua da voi e ogni volta che c'è
un'emergenza ve ne parlo e ogni volta
che c'è un fatto enorme sono pronto a
raccontarlo ma anche quando non c'è il
dramma di tutto questo è proprio che
spesso mi sento come Cassandra
un lavoro un po' da sfigati Parliamoci
chiaro perché spesso mi sono trovata a
dire in situazioni incredibili
all'inizio della guerra siriana che
morivano cinque bambini al giorno
esattamente con la stessa media con cui
muoiono in Ucraina con mio figlio sul
bagnasciuga a cercare di dire ai
giornalisti Guardate che questa guerra
diventano guerra mondiale e lui mi
tirava io cercavo di di poter raccontare
che questa sarebbe diventata una guerra
di proporzioni assurde e 12 anni è
diventata quella che è diventata molto
peggio dell'Ucraina questa bambina è una
bambina siriana l'ho incontrata in un
campo profughi dove c'erano 200.000
persone più grande del mondo dopo quello
in Kenya dadabba si chiama zatari è
diventato una città e lì e lì vive un
paese intero la guerra non è finita oggi
mentre vi parlo quella guerra continua
dura da 12 anni solo che oggi si parla
di Ucraina ma prima dell'Ucraina c'era
l'Afghanistan vi ricordate
Afghanistan l'estate scorsa eravamo
tutti disperati 15 giorni di speciali su
tutte le televisioni non si parlava
d'altro
e poi improvvisamente c'erano 18 milioni
di persone che fanno urgente bisogno di
assistenza Umanitaria la metà erano
bambini un anno dopo scoppia l'Ucraina
un anno dopo quest'estate parliamo di
Afghanistan e ci troviamo con 25 milioni
di persone in emergenza Umanitaria con
il 97% delle persone che non hanno nulla
da mangiare
che è successo ce ne siamo dimenticati
non abbiamo provato a raccontare così
complicato vedete fare il portavoce
portare la parola quando il flusso della
comunicazione si alza con ailan e poi si
riabbassa l'ha detto pure il padre
Appena si è dimenticato di Highlander
perché insomma tutti i dati a morire in
mare si alza con le bambine morte per il
gas nel 2017 nelle fosse comune siriane
e poi si riabbassa ci indigniamo e
smettiamo di indignarci io ve lo ricordo
ogni giorno e poi ce lo dimentichiamo
velocissimo perché Siamo bravissimi
aiutare a comprendere tutto questo
raccontarvi loro tutti i giorni è un
esercizio straordinario perché ci aiuta
a superare una cosa che vale per tutto
quello tutta la sfera umana tutte le
cose della nostra vita serve per non
avere paura a non avere paura di loro
perché conoscere un posto Ecco in questo
mi piacerebbe che si insegnasse la
geografia fino all'Università anche
soltanto conoscere i confini conoscere
il posto dove vivono da dove sono
partiti il tragitto che hanno fatto le
violenze che hanno subito la situazione
dei paesi dove vivono le guerre che
stanno vivendo la fame che hanno le
statistiche i numeri che ogni tanto mi
trovo a ridare serve per non avere paura
perché quando poi inevitabilmente tutto
questo Arriva nelle vostre case perché
ci arriva che sia nelle un pakistano che
scappa dalle inondazioni fino a un
Siriano che scappa dalla guerra che sia
un ucraino che fugge oggi versi confini
l'hanno fatto in 2 milioni fino
all'ultimo bambino dello Yemen tutto
questo arriva dentro le vostre case e il
modo migliore per comprendere perché lui
arriva è spiegartelo È raccontarlo ogni
minuto ogni giorno perché è l'unico
antidolo contro una verdura perché la
paura respinge perché la paura blocca
perché la paura provoca reazione Allora
siccome
non mi voglio dilungare un'altra dei
compiti che mi danno questi bambini è
riportare a voi le loro storie e siccome
dovunque sono andato io sono stato in
più di 800 città in questi ultimi anni
C'era una bambina siriana
che mi ha detto una cosa meravigliosa ve
la regalo anche a voi perché poi il
bello di questi bambini è che ti
lasciano dei messaggi straordinari ti
chiedono di lasciarli a chi ti sta
ascoltando io
esattamente 6 anni fa visita una scuola
Tra le tante che gestisce l'unicef dove
c'erano tantissime bambine siriane
Fuggite con le carriole con i genitori
dalla loro casa per arrivare in
Giordania con la carriola dove dentro
vedevi le televisioni le coperte di
tutto la prima cosa che ti capita sai
quando ti bombardano casa Non è che
c'hai tempo di prendere Prendi la prima
cosa che ti capita arrivavano a migliaia
queste bambine Noi l'abbiamo prese molti
di loro l'abbiamo portato nelle scuole a
integrarsi con le bambine Giordano
insomma per farvela breve questa bambina
che era seduta davanti a me esattamente
come voi questa sera in una classe di
bambine straordinarie che purtroppo sì
portavano il velo
qualcuna volontariamente qualcuno no
questo non lo so non è il tema di oggi
Ecco noi abbiamo cominciato a ascoltarle
come vi dicevo all'inizio a parlare con
loro
a sentire che facciamo da dirci molti di
loro ci raccontano la loro storia di
fuga molte che vogliono fare il medico
altre che volevano fare gli scienziati
altri ancora che volevano semplicemente
mettersi in pari come diciamo noi in
italiano con con le loro materie Noi
siamo entrati lì da buoni italiani anche
se eravamo operatori umanitari Abbiamo
cominciato a scrivere sulle lavagne
welcome Ciao Totti tutte le parole
italiano terribile so queste è
d'altronde serviva per rompere il
ghiaccio c'era questa bambina davanti a
me
che non parlava ed era quella che mi era
stata assegnata per poter parlare per
poterla un po' così da ascoltare
scrivere la sua storia non voleva
parlare con me questa bambina che si
chiama tuttora Nur Che vuol dire luce in
arabo alla fine di questo incontro che
abbiamo fatto
Grazie ai miei colleghi dell'Unicef mi
si è avvicinata insieme al traduttore mi
ha detto le posso raccontare una storia
la mia storia lei al portavoce
dell'Unicef è vero Ho detto sì può
raccontare questa storia agli italiani
quando torna a casa e le ho promesso di
sì si è avvicinata mi ha guardato negli
occhi e mi ha detto può raccontare agli
italiani che hanno sparato in testa a
mio padre perché pensavano fosse un
ribelle
e non sapevo che rispondere a nulla
perché hai 3 secondi per rispondere e ti
vengono in mente un sacco di cose in tre
secondi ma la prima cosa che mi è venuta
in mente è stata e
come sta
e non si è girata è scappata via e
scappando mi ha detto adesso sta bene Da
quel giorno promettendour che aveva
raccontato ovunque la sua storia e sono
le storie che mi lasciano questi bambini
qua i miei datori di lavoro Grazie
[Applauso]